examen aujourd'hui par les députés du
projet de loi pour réparer la tragédie a
requis un texte pour demander pardon à
ces algériens qui ont servi la france et
que paris a abandonné je cite dans des
conditions indignes plus de détails tout
de suite avec katia pique nique en
direct de l'assemblée nationale
katia le projet de loi est il à la
hauteur des attentes
oui en effet grégory enfin dans un sens
en tout cas car il reconnaît les
services rendus en algérie par les
anciens membres des formations
supplétives qui ont servi la france et
qu'elle a délaissé lors du processus
d'indépendance de ce pays voilà pour le
projet de loi emmanuel macron avait
promis donc une loi pour ce que la
france a abandonné après l'indépendance
de l'algérie en 1962 200 milliards qui
ont combattu dans les rangs de l'armée
française entre 54 et 62 et cette loi
est très bien elle était attendue depuis
60 ans tout de même 90 milliards qui ont
été parqués en france dans des
conditions indignes dans des camps dans
ce qu'on appelle des hameaux de
forestage et la loi permet de ta
permettra de les indemniser en
réparation de ce préjudice avec une
somme forfaitaire en fonction de la
durée du séjour 50 millions d'euros ont
été inscrits dans le projet de budget
2022 pour doter un fonds d'indemnisation
il est prévu que 6000 dossiers soient
indemnisés soldé en 2022
oui katia commandes devraient voter les
députés
alors il devrait recueillir un large
avalant de la part des parlementaires et
tout le monde est d'accord les entend
discuter débattre ils sont d'accord sur
la dimension symbolique 1 reconnaître de
la france porte une lourde
responsabilité
en tout cas sur le reste les débats vont
bon train premier problème les harkis
pour recevoir une somme forfaitaire qui
est un peu un solde de tout compte même
si on pourrait déterminer des préjudices
spécifiques selon les situations au cas
par cas or la ministre de la mémoire et
des anciens combattants geneviève
darrieussecq et dans l'hémicycle en ce
moment là assuré que les préjudices
moraux seront aussi pris en compte et
puis surtout il ya un gros problème
d'indemnisation car tous les harkis ne
seront pas indemnisés de la même manière
et je vous propose d'écouter alexis
corbière à ce sujet député la france
insoumise
le projet de loi du gouvernement veut
réparer ceux qui sont passés par des
camps transit terre défini et en quatre
lieux absolument scandaleux où il y
avait et privation de liberté où il ya
vraiment des conditions de vie donnons
accès aux soins de non accès à
l'éducation c'est un univers carcéral
qui a été terrible mais en même temps on
sait aussi qu'il ya plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de harkis qui ont parfois
n'ont pas été accueillis dans ces lieux
de privation de liberté mais dans des
quartiers où des sites est reléguée dans
certaines villes leur condition aussi de
vie était absolument terrible et ça a
amené beaucoup de souffrance
psychologique de déscolarisation etc et
nous pensons qu'il faut aujourd'hui
indemniser tout le monde tire que sont
on parle si à deux cent mille personnes
est il acceptable non indemnisé
peut-être 90 mines et dans l'essai 100
milles sur le côté je crois que la
guerre est finie
la l'état français a tellement faute et
si je viens dans ce dossier que c'est
pas le monde d'être de mesquins
alors françois ruffin a dénoncé des
critères et trois députés de la france
insoumise qui dit que ça éliminer la
moitié des arcs et au niveau de
l'indemnisation et surtout il a blâmé
des montants dérisoires pas la hauteur
des situations d'horreur qui ont été
décrites il ya peu à l'assemblée
nationale quelques milliers d'euros par
exemple pour la plupart des harkis en ce
moment donc c'est précisément l'objet de
débats d'une part le montant et d'autre
part le fait que de nombreux députés
souhaitent que tous les arts qu'ils
soient considérés comme ayant vécu un
préjudice qu'ils étaient détenus dans un
camp ou simplement qu'ils aient vécu
dans un bidonville ou autres logements
insalubres et dans l'hémicycle pendant
ce temps là la ministre geneviève
darrieussecq souhaite rassurer mais elle
veut rester dans l'esprit de la loi
indemnisés en cas de mise sous tutelle
ou de privation de liberté
merci katia pique nique pour toutes ces
précisions en direct donc du
palais-bourbon merci aussi à sébastien
dufour qui est avec vous mais derrière
la caméra